hi there steve kaufman here
um i said i think in an answer by the
way uh please subscribe to my channel if
you enjoy uh hearing and talking about
the issues surrounding language learning
and if you like this video give it a
like
uh today i want to talk about three
months because three months comes up
quite often
we have our 90-day challenges at link i
have done quite a few i've done it in
polish in
korean in
arabic and persian and maybe some other
i can't remember
uh three months we had the three months
to fluency of that
you know benny the irish polyglot spoke
of
it's a period of time where we can sort
of focus our energies and hopefully
achieve something
so i want to talk a bit about that i had
said that i was going to talk about
learning you know more than one language
at the same time or that i was going to
talk about you know getting to speaking
and and both of those things i want to
talk about but i want to talk about them
next thursday and i want to have a live
streaming session such as we used to
have so that means that we'll go on for
45 minutes so however long
you will sign up and we'll get the
information out to you on on how you can
sign up and you can post your questions
and i will answer those questions live
and i want to focus it on the idea of
sort of learning and maintaining several
languages and the issue of getting to
speaking and we can talk about those
things at that
live streaming event now
the three months so what can we achieve
in three months and and how should we
approach
uh sort of a three-month period of time
so first of all i will sort of recount
for you sort of my recent
experience in sort of three months okay
so i my wife and i went to israel
okay so i got this t-shirt
from the hebrew university
in tel aviv
and i put in probably
three weeks prior to going there into
hebrew
uh i would say that my hebrew is
non-existent okay even trying to read it
whatever i did i've essentially
forgotten so with hebrew i only put in a
few weeks
uh if i start up again
i'm almost starting at the beginning
i'll be a little bit better because i'll
be refreshing things that i tried to do
and so it'll come back faster and
stronger but i have essentially zero
there okay but as a result of
going to israel then my wife and i went
into jordan and we visited petra
and
that made me think um
really there's an awful lot more arabic
speakers than hebrew speakers i'm going
to learn arabic so as a result of
starting to learn hebrew i was motivated
to learn arabic and this comes back to a
point that i always have experienced in
my life and that is you never know
what's going to lead to what one and one
doesn't always equal two the main thing
is to actually do something and if you
do something good things will happen
so i then went into arabic and i spent
you know off and on because i was
traveling in latin america i was
traveling in ukraine and stuff but i put
in about seven or eight months into
arabic
then i said
you know i have now learned to read
arabic more or less
and there's a lot of uh persian speakers
farsi speakers here in
vancouver why don't i learn
persian so i spent essentially three
months
with persian at the end of which i did a
brief
um
video
and then
my wife is watching turkish
soap operas on netflix so i said hey i'd
like to understand what they're saying
so i got into turkish and i've now spent
about two months on turkish so here's my
feeling about three months
three months is a good period especially
if you are starting
a new language now anyone that is
starting a new language
or has studied other languages is
already by definition
uh an enjoyment learner okay that's
different from a person who needs
english for their job a person who needs
english for their job they're going to
be totally focused on english but in my
case i learn it because it's enjoyable
and what do i achieve in three months
well first of all how so i avoid
too much time on grammar explanations
because i don't have any sense of the
language i certainly never do grammar
exercises i focus entirely on listening
and reading and i focus on
the many stories because the first time
i listen i'm just accumulating words
and and the first time i study these
lessons i'm accumulating words and only
slowly do i start to notice
the different forms the different
functions of the different forms and
even today while cleaning up after
breakfast
i noticed certain things about turkish
verbs that i hadn't noticed before
and however the other day
driving to the office i put in my arabic
you know i listened to arabic
and i listened to the
persian coming back from the office
i heard the words more clearly than i
did before
in other words spending time with
turkish
has
increased my
ability to clearly hear these other
languages and i've always found that
studying new languages was kind of like
a an exercise for the brain which uh
improves your ability to hear
other languages however obviously i have
slipped
i've forgotten things
so
i kind of end up with sort of the
following
feeling about the first three months of
a language okay you cannot achieve
fluency in three months because
fluency requires lots of practice using
the using the language speaking the
language eventually you have to speak a
lot you have to speak in meaning of
meaningful situations not just uh hello
how are you where's the bathroom but
talking about things of interest a wide
range of subjects lots of speaking until
you have had that you will not be fluent
so three months of study after three
months you don't have the vocabulary to
engage in meaningful conversation and
therefore it's not
practical to think that you can be
fluent in three months however
i have a level in arabic
turkish even
and persian
that i don't slip that much i listen to
my arabic i listen to my
uh persian i'm aware of certain
structures in the language i'm aware of
vocabulary there
i've slipped some
when i go back to doing those languages
and go back to some of the same content
some of the same many stories
refresh what's in my brain you know i
get right back to where i was and go
forward
so the three-month period gives you that
toehold
the language is now no longer strange
you have a certain amount of vocabulary
some of which you'll forget but which
you can quickly relearn
the culture and the people
are no longer strange
uh if i
even if i watch people speak arabic and
and and farsi and turkish and i don't
understand what they're saying i have a
sense of who they are i have a sense of
that culture so i have this ability now
by having my sort of arabic was eight
months but three months on persian two
months on turkish i've discovered this
whole new world so the goal of the first
three months
is not to achieve fluency because
even when for example as a spanish
speaker i learned
portuguese
uh i i put in more than three months
uh and this was before we had portuguese
at link so i was using living language
and stuff like that but still went to
portugal i was dead like people just
switched back to english they didn't
have patience for me i had to put in
more time then i went to portugal and
then slowly i started getting enough
interaction with people to where i can
even today i don't really call myself
tremendously fluent in portuguese
because i mix in so much spanish or
italian or whatever so three months is a
key period to
first of all get that sense that you can
learn the language get us some sense of
achievement
some sense of familiarity with the
language
don't worry about how correctly you use
the language it won't matter until
you've had you know come across these
same words and phrases in different
situations and you start to notice the
function of different words and then you
can of course look up grammar when
you're curious and i do that like just
today i google
uh you know noun
cases in turkish or verbs in turkish or
suffixes in turkish so you can always
refer to these sources and maybe
refer to several different sources and
then you go back to your reading and
listening and you start noticing
different things
but fluency is not the goal the goal is
to say okay i now have a toehold in this
language i have a better understanding
of the culture it's something that i
have with me that i can always go back
to whenever i want and that's what we
want to achieve with that first three
month period so i have a number of these
now on the back burner
you know greek romanian i don't have
enough time
uh obviously to to bring them all up to
the level that i'd like to be at but
whatever i have put into those is well
worth it was time well invested and so
that's basically all you can expect to
do in your first three months with a
language thank you and remember next
thursday we have a live streaming
session and i look forward to seeing you
there and we will be providing uh
information on how you can participate
bye for now
you